dernière étape stratégique pour les
candidats dans la course à la maison
blanche
l'actuel locataire donald trump a
vivement critiqué ce lundi joe biden qui
tentent de le déloger le président
américain accuse son rival et sa
colistière kamala harris de politiser la
recherche contre le coronavirus après
que la sénatrice démocrate a affirmé
qu'elle ne croirait pas la seule parole
du candidat républicain sur le sujet
donald trump a en effet récemment évoqué
l'arrivée prochaine d'un vaccin contre
le coc vite 19 et un rebond inédit de
l'économie juste avant l'élection
hayden et sa colistière très libéral la
personne la plus libérale du congrès
d'ailleurs et qui n'est pas une personne
compétente d'après moi ils vont détruire
ce pays vont détruire cette économie il
devrait immédiatement s'excuser pour
leur prudence rhétorique anti vaccins
qu'ils emploient en ce moment dans ce
discours improvisé dédiée aux
travailleurs américain donald trump a
également accusé son rival de vouloir
vivre et les emplois du pays à la chine
et face aux manifestations anti racistes
qui ont marqué le pays ces dernières
semaines
le président dénonce un soutien du camp
démocrate aux militants radicaux face
aux invectives du milliardaire joe biden
a défendu sa position
l'un des problèmes avec sa façon de
jouer avec la politique et qu'il dit
tellement de choses qui ne sont pas vrai
que je crains que même si nous avons un
vrai bon vaccin des personnes hésiteront
à aller se faire vacciner
ils savent donc la confiance du public
mais prions dieu que nous en ayons un si
je pouvais avoir un bon vaccin demain je
le ferai si cela me coûtait l'élection
je le ferai nous avons besoin d'un
vaccin et nous en avons besoin
maintenant le plus vite possible
la pandémie de kovy 19 est au centre de
la présidentielle depuis des mois et
influe sur les stratégies de campagne
des deux camps six meetings électoraux
en six semaines et du porte à porte pour
soutenir la réélection de donald trump
du côté des démocrates pas de porte à
porte ni de meetings pour éviter la
propagation du virus
une stratégie en forme de paris alors
que donald trump s'est félicité de ces
récents résultats dans les sondages